we've just heard from the bank of
England just now Jane with a rather
extraordinary statement saying that they
are planning a guilt Market operation
which is an intervention from the bank
of England they say to try to restore
orderly market conditions let me just
read out part of this statement
literally just in the last few minutes
from the bank of England they say
um as the governor said in the statement
on Monday the bank is monitoring
developments in financial markets very
closely in light of the significant
repricing of UK and Global Financial
assets the repricing has become more
significant in the past day and it's
particularly affecting long-dated UK
government debt now what they're talking
about there is essentially part of the
thing we've been talking about recently
the yields on government debt which have
spiked up to the highest rate that we've
seen since the financial crisis that the
statement goes on with dysfunction in
this market to continue or worsen there
would be a material risk to UK Financial
stability this would lead an unwarranted
tightening of financial conditions and a
reduction in the flow of credit to the
real economy so essentially saying that
this could well it's we're already
seeing it aren't we you were just
talking to Ian about this the fact that
mortgage lenders are pulling some of
their products because of what's
happening right now uh in line with its
Financial stability operation so the
bank has two roles here uh they they
have a role of dealing with what's going
on in the monetary side that's interest
rates and financial stability as well so
looking making sure the market can
function the bank stands ready to
restore Market functioning and reduce
any risks from contagion to credit
conditions for UK head businesses and
households this is the key pit bit sorry
I'm reading this out because we have
literally just got it to achieve this
the bank will carry out temporary
purchases of long-dated UK government
bonds from the 28th of September so
that's what they are planning to do
obviously that's from today the purpose
of these purchases will be to restore
orderly market conditions the purchases
will be carried carried out on whatever
scale is necessary to affect this
outcome and whatever scale is necessary
to affect this outcome the operation
will be fully indemnified by hm treasury
so it's been coordinated with the
treasury
um that's I mean that I I could go on
but that's the main part of this
statement
this is not quite similar to
quantitative easing that's one of the
things that you know many of you might
have thought when you heard about the
government kind of going in and buying
government debt because it's not to
fulfill a monetary objective it's to try
to calm those markets down and get them
functioning properly this is the bank
intervening to try to get the markets
working again and intervening on you
know quite a novel basis I don't recall
seeing anything quite like this during
the financial crisis and it's
specifically looking at the Government
Bond Market the idea is that you know
they can see what's happening right now
as we can they are worried about it and
where we've got their statement on
Monday this is going further than the
statement this is actually intervening
and obviously follows the imf's
announcement yesterday of their concern
so we've just had that just explain
sorry but just explain to us what the
bank will carry out temporary purchases
of long-dated government bonds in
layman's terms what does that mean it
means they are going so so long days of
government bonds that is basically those
uh it's government debt it's government
debt that the government issues to try
to finance itself
um and the bank has two roles it has a
role of just making sure that interest
rates are kind of working and getting
out there into the economy but it also
has another role to make sure that all
of the markets and that includes these
Government Bond markets includes other
markets as well seem to be functioning
properly and what they do is they
monitor that to make sure that there are
no disturbances and to make sure that
money is able to get out there to people
who need it and that's their verdict on
that latter part the financial stability
part that they need to step in to make
sure these markets are functioning I'm
sorry I'm looking down at my kind of
screen because literally the statement
has just arrived
um and the risk really is that you see
what's happening now and this I think is
what's in the minds of the policy makers
at the bank who have been monitoring
this you see what's going on in the
interest rate on those long data
government data and remember those
interest rates have gone up from kind of
where they were around kind of three
percent four percent well three percent
or so up to four and four and a half
percent I think this morning on at least
the 10-year government debt those are
movements which you know as Ian said
before and I'm sure will reiterate this
is almost unprecedented it's certainly
very unusual to see such big movements
uh in these markets and that in turn
affects all of the rest of us because if
you've got that kind of yoyoing around
it means getting money to people who
need it whether through mortgages or
other kinds of lending becomes very
difficult and you see kind of what
you're seeing at the moment which is
mortgage lenders just pulling back
saying we're not quite sure what to do
with our products how to price them at
the moment because the market looks so
unstable so the fact that the bank has
intervened in this way it's not an
interest rate hike well there you can
see the news release it's not an
interest rate hike which is what some
people might have been expecting from
the bank it is something else it's
something unusual it is an intervention
which
like I say I can't remember anything
quite like it because it's not like
quantitative easing where they're
printing money in order to buy
government debt they are getting money
out there uh which I assume is not going
to be monetarily financed although I'm
going to have to you know have a have a
deeper look at this they are getting
money out there to try to Target parts
of the Government Bond Market that they
feel aren't really functioning right now
so an extraordinary intervention from
the bank of England will bring you more
on precisely how it works and what the
implications could be as well of course
as the market reaction actually if you
wait there I will literally just look at
my screen while I'm talking to you and
just see what's happening to guilt
markets well look I could I'm just
looking at the rates on UK government
dares which is this is what we're
talking about him I'm looking at the 10
month the 10-year bond and the yield on
that as I say which is what I'm talking
about is down from 4.5 percent straight
away it dropped down to about 4.2
percent again a very big move indeed
it's come out about 4.3 4.37 at the
moment
so we're seeing some big movements here
some big reaction everyone out there in
the market trying to understand what the
bank is doing here it's clear though
that they are intervening because they
are very concerned deeply concerned
about what's happening in financial
markets right now